there you go buddy what do you got for
me
hey what's going on rich what's up
brother so
i just got the kids down
um a little less about solution but
it touches on it and maybe you covered
this in uh in the last video but um i
just can't get the quote out of my mind
and i'm gonna butcher it but
you know when they came for the plumbers
i didn't say anything because i wasn't a
plumber you know when they came for the
bakers i didn't say anything because it
wasn't a baker you know and then
eventually it gets to you or whatever it
is you know when they came for me there
was no one left right
and so you know should we do something i
just can't get that out of my mind if we
don't do something at some point
you know we're the last one standing and
and the last ones uh that they're going
to be coming for and so
i feel like there's got to be some it's
more pragmatic than if we have
you know this big obligation to do
something for others you know to me it
comes down to self-preservation and uh
it's like the frog in the pot right like
it doesn't know that it's being boiled
because it gets cooked so slowly
most of society is so resilient to all
of this nonsense it's like you know like
one thing at a time like they they never
claw back the tax rates they always tax
you more right it's like they just
slowly kind of do it over time and it's
like you know they came up with taxation
why because they ran into a bunch of
debt decades ago and they're like well
we need to pay the [ __ ] off so we're
just going to tax you for a little bit
but we promise it's only temporary
and it's like yeah i mean that that's
how that's just
like right
getting a little feedback yeah that's
totally the the tools of tyranny right
is to chip away but there's also this
element of um
particularly in western in the western
uh in the western world
and particularly in america canada i
mean we're just so fat and numb
right i mean we're numbed by tv we're
numbed by porn we're numb by booze we're
numbed by gossip you know
goes back to the i don't care blog that
i just read though right it's like why
do we want to care about all this stuff
we don't have any control out of it and
it's and we've always been in us versus
them
society right
no yeah absolutely but i think that's
why we see this decline because we're so
numb we're fine with a little concession
here a little concession there it's it's
back for your frog in the in the pot
right that's what's happening around us
and some of us are clued in a little bit
more of the writing on the wall as you
said earlier right we we see what's
happening and then the question comes do
we do anything about it is is there a
solution um do we feel like there's a
meaningful impact we can have and if so
is it worth our time and effort and and
the other thing i think is interesting
most of the people that are having this
debate
we're having the debate because we're
focused on kicking ass for ourselves to
begin with right we're not crying about
things we're not complaining there's a
wall in front of us we're just climbing
over it or going around it or going
under it right and that generally is red
pill
to a degree conservative philosophy just
get [ __ ] done right versus crying and
whining and complaining and
and that's why you see less of us in
public office because we got stuff to do
we got families to take care of we got
ourselves our businesses so but it just
comes back to that quote i feel like
we've got to do something that's
pragmatic if if for no other reason then
so why can't you limit the something to
your inner circle like why can't you
draw a perimeter around us well that's
certainly where you have to start yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying right like
start start there you know take care of
yourself take care of your own you know
draw that draw that perimeter and look
if you want to widen that perimeter
and add five ten more people to it have
have some more impact you know some more
reach cool do it because i mean you've
taken care of number one first right
oh 100 you got to put your oxygen mask
on first i mean that right that's in the
micro right in your freaking
relationships you got to take care of
yourself first it's the same thing in
society and everything on the micro
also works on the macro despite what
these politicians are telling us
and you know that they're i mean like
that's where you run in the roadblock so
where they really start to push back
like you know like you know the stuff
that i talk about so i mean like you're
a member of the community you know we
have some dialogue back and forth
privately obviously you know from time
to time but
a lot of the stuff that
you get
you know that the other guys get and we
have like field reports on and we kind
of like swap some notes on that sort of
stuff
that's that's very unique like that's a
very small percentage of the population
most of the people when they hear me
talk about certain ideas like if i say
something like you know men and women
are different for these five reasons a
lot of women will lose their [ __ ] and a
lot of white knights will lose their
[ __ ]
right it's like you know how can you say
these things like you know how can you
possibly say these things like this is
not you know this this sheds light that
i don't like right and it's like i feel
offended now and it turns into all these
other components and sort of stuff like
that that's why i'm just saying you know
we're still in an us versus them sort of
space and if you can draw that perimeter
take care of your number ones you know
build build something up that you can
enjoy you know that vessel that ark
whatever the hell it is that you want to
call it
and then invite people onto your ark
that vessel and then just kind of say
sail into the sunset and just enjoy the
decline together sort of thing if you
want to pick up some people along the
way do that but i don't think that it's
a good use of time effort and resources
to like
mill over that
set of sound bites that you pull out at
the beginning
so
i'm listening to a podcast right now
with my kids it's called um growing
patriots there's any parents on there
i'd recommend it but uh it's a podcast
that goes through early american history
and one of the things i learned that i
wasn't quite aware of and didn't grasp
completely is that um
only about 30 percent of the population
during the revolutionary uh time period
revolutionary were actually supported
independents
the other 30 or 40 percent were
loyalists to britain and the rest were
like just keep me out of it keep my head
down kind of like what you're saying i'm
on my boat you know i just don't want to
get caught in the middle i'm doing my
thing yeah um but
that reflected on me pretty heavily that
only 30 percent
really you know got on board and made
this thing happen that had such a
positive impact on the development of
western culture
um you know the fact that most people
are going to get pissed off by your
statement that men and women are
different you know doesn't mean it you
know we we should stop saying it or that
we should just be in that other 25 30
percent that's that's focusing on
yourself yeah that's a good resource
right like like this is a good resource
now the question then becomes like how
do you get
all kids to drink this kool-aid
because right now like i can tell by the
number of episodes and the ratings that
the reach is very
it's it's basically abysmal it's like
non-existent there's not a lot of people
yeah and i don't know what the content
looks like so i'm not endorsing it or
rejecting it i'm just saying that the
notions that you're discussing you're a
smart guy and i trust you and i like you
so i'm assuming it's good but how would
you get
like
because they get the indoctrination
through the school system right it's
critical race theory and wokeness and
that political correctness and you can't
you can't say words in school anymore
like you can't say [ __ ] in school
anymore that was like you know when we
were kids in school yeah they'd be like
ah shut up your [ __ ] and you just kind
of go and you you know go about your day
now it's like people lose their [ __ ] if
you say that
well i think there's two things
happening there one
you know i think you and i would agree
that there were some things that needed
to be addressed but the problem is the
pendulum swings too far right and then
people take it too far
and so and and that's generally how
anything happens is they take something
a little
and they blow it out of proportion or it
gets it becomes a monster of unintended
consequences but the second is the
gentleman that you had onto talking
about education
that's an intentional by design marxist
leftist strategy i mean they've been
talking about integrating and infecting
and and targeting the education system
for probably about three decades now
that is part of their strategy oh yeah
so it's a you know strategy for strategy
to counter i think the rise of of uh of
based education or whatever you want to
call you have your kids in the public
school system or a private school system
private school right and
um on the naval base they say the pledge
of allegiance they're still a chris
christmas pageant okay um so and that
was an important move uh that my ex-wife
and i um agreed on in may but
you know
even that is not you know perfect but
you know it's an 80 20 approach and it's
much better than the public but um
there's a great book about public
education called get out now
and it talks about just how bad the
public school system really is and it's
you know it's all because
a small amount of people exert a huge
amount of pressure on one administrator
on one school district you know they get
these activists across the country
coming down
you know like a hammer on one district
to get what they want right and then
they use that as an example and they go
to the next and they go to the next
they're not going to stop right so if we
you know
enjoy the climb well there's a couple
things there one
how long is the decline going to last
before it really [ __ ] really hits the
fan and we're not talking about enjoying
the decline we're talking about
surviving the decline right and that's a
different conversation and so surviving
is going to come from a from a collapse
right like we're not talking about
surviving we're
we're just assuming that they're going
to keep on kicking the can down the road
in our lifetime
well then and then you got your kids you
know you looked out at them and you're
like what are they going to inherit yeah
i think we got it at least i get it
you know i get it but i mean like
the west but pragmatically camp
you know like like i get it and to you
know to one degree like it's like you
know i'm kind of glad i got a daughter
because it's like like women
like if you understand
they went either way yeah yeah except
except that they're part of that 60
unhappy blue pill women right right yeah
well yeah there's i mean there's all
kinds of problems that kind of like pile
onto this right it's it's it's it's just
you know we could have this conversation
for hours but it's just like hey you
know what man i think that we agree that
things are on the decline so
like like do we agree that you can't
enjoy it as it's as it's going about 100
i mean you have to find joy and
gratitude what about money though
because i mean like money obviously
matters right because i mean you have
the ability to put your kids in private
school right so
like do you need money to enjoy the
decline like would you say that or do
you disagree with that i think it
depends on your individual circumstance
i you know i just was mentioning the
other day to a buddy of mine if i didn't
have my kids i'd be
in a customized van that i built myself
driving through sedona right now right i
mean and i'd be able to do it pretty
cost effectively um you do need money
but you know there's some there was an
interesting video from uh someone uh
what jennifer moleski or whatever do you
uh follow her at all
uh she's like the dating advice chick
uh
kind of she's you know anti-blame
anti-victimhood i think she was at one
of the conferences uh a while back she
didn't do so at the conference but i
like her channel she had a good video
recently just talked about
you know money being a tool and the way
that it flows and she framed it well
you can make you can make money in this
environment i mean there's so many you
know
so many different rabbit holes that you
can go down you got to be intentional
about it
um but money money isn't really an issue
if you're putting in in the time and
effort um if you've got an iq over 110
and then
and maybe even less than that right i
mean persistence is is is is all that it
really takes at the end of the day but i
agree yeah you need a certain amount of
money of course you know based off of
what you want your comfort level and
what you want your lifestyle i'd say
that it's mandatory though if you want
to enjoy the decline but i mean you
couldn't enjoy it like
so
here's so here's the problem that most
people have is that is that they don't
have freedom
to maneuver they don't have access to
financial resources and stored value
they're reliant on
it like they say that if you
uh
like a i think it was uh kevin o'leary
that said this but he said something
along the lines of
they
they give you a salary to kill your
dreams or
or a salary is a drug that they give you
to like kill your dreams you know
basically
and there's also the people that are
also on government assistance that rely
on on state handouts
so that means they have to keep voting
for state handouts
which is good which is big government
you know socialism programs and more
programs universal income it's coming
yeah yeah and like the more people they
can have kind of plugged into the
employment system
where
like right now we're seeing the
government mandate employers to have
their employees vaccinated
right so it's like the government says
you have to do this then then the
companies say okay well if we don't do
this and we're going to
incur fines whatever taxes or something
like that so we're going to make our
employees do this so it's like you know
this trickle-down effect so they so they
still have control that way so whether
you're on the government t sitting at
home or you're on the government team
working for somebody you're on the
government team
right
well i think it's you know it's back to
the phrase you've used in the past are
you
are you bringing do you want to bring in
[ __ ] you money do you want to not just
enjoy it but do you want to be able to
be vocal do
you know unbound
say anything go anywhere you know with
with uh you know a certain level of
impunity or or lack of risk that they
can cancel you versus do you just want
to enjoy it right you want to be
quiet in the shadows doing your thing
right and enjoying your day to day
but those are kind of different areas
right um and i i want to get to
um
being able to live my truth vocally so
my kids can see the type of
man uh i want have you have you have you
gotten up on a platform and started
broadcasting that anywhere
in terms of my thoughts and beliefs and
and and where i stand on issues yeah
yeah because i mean like you've got this
hope that you know things can be saved
like you know like how do we remedy this
so that my kids don't live in a [ __ ]
up world basically you know i've got a
mixed bag and and and you know
frankly i'm also part of the problem
because some parts of my business
propagate some of this false narrative
because of just kind of the business
model that i'm in
uh and i'm not particularly proud of
that
um but i certainly you know i feel like
i'm trying to do my part in small ways
you know even if it's just something
like the vax you know i don't have a
hundred employees but i certainly have a
good number
and um you know they know that it's it's
up to them it's their own personal
choice and i've been very clear about
that so there's small ways that i'm
trying to do it but
i kind of came around to some of this
thinking and and some of my my positions
just in the last year and a half through
through my divorce and kind of thinking
and also just how rapidly
culture has changed in the last five
years right and i'm like
hold hold up but um
yeah i have a relatively uh
um
tenuous position um i could not be as
vocal about everything as i would like
to be
at least right now and and my intent is
is to change that
uh and then when i get to that space
it's very difficult to change it though
because i mean like you can't be vocal
for your own reasons tied into what
you're doing and even if you didn't have
those liabilities like if you didn't
have those anchors and you went on a
platform let's say like youtube and you
wanted to like broadcast yourself freely
you can't because they censor you right
well yeah so it's like how do you
how do you communicate that right you
know
that's why i just keep going back to you
you know what the best use of my time
build that perimeter form your tribe
take care of it
that's it you know you know i would
challenge that thought a little bit rich
i mean you i think you yeah some of what
you say is hidden behind your membership
wall but a lot of it's it's out there
and
it may not be able to be monetized you
know through the channel but like you
notice that the conversations we have on
zoo versus what we're having publicly
sure
these are a lot more watered down like
we don't get into specifics oh of course
you know but but that's all that's kind
of
everything right you gotta you gotta
crawl walk run and if you came in came
in hot right at the start you know it
would people need to be they need to be
led right and it's a process and the
same way they're incrementally
taking them down this ridiculous
cultural road we got to incrementally
show them the light and be beacons and
you're right it starts with taking care
of yourself taking care of your
surroundings being someone that
someone's like hey
how did you do that like what's your you
know just like that guy on the um in the
group the other day was talking about
his brother-in-law like you invite him
out for a beer you mentioned a couple
things and see if
he doesn't
you know you you don't diary of the
mouth and throw up on him because he's
just not ready for it you know yeah i
can say this i mean like one of the
things that i am mindful of is like you
know i talk about concepts and ideas and
it's like i
i need to embody them and and i won't
talk about things that are a violation
of the beliefs that i rule in my own
life right so when i tell you guys to
[ __ ] learn how to fight
i'm at the dojo several times a week
learning how to fight right like like
when i say self-care matters like
i'm not fat like you know
i'm on my bike i'm doing my cardio
conditioning like i take care of myself
right so i you know i can lead by
example in that way i think that's a
great thing that you know that we can do
as men is you know set those examples
for
our own kids and and people that look at
us you know even if they even if they
want to flick boogers at me right
because i get a lot of that there's a
lot of nerds out there that think that
they know better you know hiding behind
their computer screen and a fake avatar
there's a lot of this stuff that like
goes on where where where people try to
challenge you right and it's like
dude you know get in the ring man get in
the ring
oh well totally i mean that's all noise
that's distraction that's not even if
they're you know uh what's the other
quote um
criticism rarely comes from uh above it
always comes from below right people
that see you pushing you know they
respect the the
the battle and and the effort people
below you that aren't doing anything are
the ones that want to throw the knives
and um but you said something earlier
too what was it about um
you know our anchors and our hang-ups
and and whether or not we can live that
truth i think that's part that's got to
be some part of the solution is that
we've got to introduce these thoughts
earlier on before people make these
decisions to give to go take a job
paying them 150 or they can't say peep
right without fear that they're going to
lose or without going along or they get
involved in the wrong relationship with
someone with totally different
philosophy and they feel like they can't
say peep and then they've got kids and
then they're tied with that and
you know we've got a you know
there's another member of the group
that's uh 10 years older
and he likes to bring up um hey man you
know you got 10 more years with this
truth than i did and then we busted
moths uh balls because he's got he's 10
years younger than i am so i'm like well
freaking chris has got 20 years you know
uh jump on on on you and 10 on me so
figuring out how to teach these lessons
earlier and i've recently picked up
rolo's book um book number two that has
the chapters about
uh parenting so reading through that and
you know i think it does start with our
kids right and making sure that they've
got the right mindset to go out into
this world and if enough people have
that
then you know then the seats see changes
because ultimately these people that
we're going against
you know they're not producers they're
not producing things right net takers
they're tinker so at some point right
that the balance starts to shift again
and um
and you also mentioned something about
politicians earlier i saw another video
i thought was interesting that uh power
and politicians or or power is
inherently anti-intellectual
right because uh
critical thought and explain why a lot
of politicians are so dumb
well and and and because those things
you know thoughts and reflection uh
pondering
uh it challenges power right so power
almost er and by default has to be
anti-intellectual right it's gotta it's
gotta dumb itself down to attempt uh to
do what it needs to do which is to get
people in line
and it doesn't wanna have those critical
conversations yeah um
yeah so that i mean there's a there's
there's a lot there but i at least five
percent uh of our efforts got to be
you know to to the greater good because
otherwise uh we gotta at least stem the
tide so we've got some faith on our
deathbed that our kids have a fighting
challenge i'm doing what i can here you
know with the youtubes of the world to
try to impart you know what i see and
you know there's some stuff people agree
with some stuff that people don't agree
with right sure of course i don't regret
i mean yeah yeah yeah you know we can
always agree to disagree that's how
that's how proper situations work that's
right that's how it used to work that's
how it's how it used to work man it used
to be like hey i got vaccinated cool did
you get vaccinated no i didn't think it
was worth my while okay cool all right
cool then you just kind of walk away
that's how we normally work right yeah
yeah well we've we've lost a lot of what
normal but hey it's been a great chat i
appreciate it
all right see you bro
you